thank all of you for coming share our
project that is ongoing we're in the
middle of we're sort of that six-month
mark of doing this project and we're
just allowed to talk to other than hear
your feedback as well we're excited
about it I think you've got a brief
description of who we are but we are
that so we are individually we're also a
team that was put together to do this
digital humanities project and you'll
hear more about how the team came
together as I mean particularly Lauren
well actually how everybody talks about
it but one of the interesting things to
me has been to see the team develop as a
team and to see people with distinct
interests and abilities be able to start
to learn how to work together on a
project like this and I'm very deeply
convinced that the digital humanities or
whatever you want to call it because
that term is contested one of the
brilliant things it has to offer for us
in the future is the production of these
teams that discover new ways of working
in the instance of having a problem to
solve and working on that problem
together and that's what we have we have
a problem to solve and it's been
exhilarating to learn and to grow in
terms of solving that problem the
problem is re visualizing and making
available in new ways the Farm Security
Administration office of War Information
photographic archive which is housed in
the library of congress and Barber said
that many of you are librarians and so
many of you know about the FSA owi
archive already and know that the
Library of Congress has put a lot of
work into making it available digitally
and there's a hundred and seventy
thousand odd even more visual images and
they've done I mean that's the go-to
place for so many people look
for the history of the mid 20th century
in the United States partly because of
course the public owns those images so
those images are basically free so those
are the images that document the 1930s
and early 40s in most histories of the
country very important photographers
worked on that project however we found
an its Lauren story really she found but
lots of other historians have found that
it wasn't it isn't available in the
optimal way that no technology has
allowed it to be available and so that's
what we have undertaken to do and that's
what we're going to share with you today
so the farm security administration
office of War Information photograph
collection was really run by a Columbia
person Roy Stryker who was professor of
economics here at Columbia before he was
brought to Washington and it was
strikers brilliance and genius to want
to make a visual record that could
support the New Deal programs that were
being rolled out there's a lot of
opposition to the New Deal to handing
money to in digital securing family
farms when actually in disgust really
farming was the way to the future there
were a lot of interests that were
against the federal government's
intervention in the depression and they
all of those the alphabet laws and
striker for a very short time had a
mandate to try to produce propaganda
really support of the government's
efforts and striker understood that
photography could be used like nothing
else to to to make this file and striker
had the capacity the genius and the
ability to flow with the flow to attract
and hire people like Walker Evans
Dorothea Lange russell lee Arthur
Rothstein been Sean jack delano Marion
post Walcott Gordon Parks JAMA Sean Karl
my tins this is the list of people
created the documentary image of the
United States and they worked for
striker so they worked for the American
the US government it's the largest
government supported arts project that
the United States has ever produced
nothing like that has ever happened to
get and they went all over the United
States and the mainland and Puerto Rico
the main office unit was in Washington
DC they distributed the photographers
got their equipment from the government
they sent the negatives back to the
government to DC to develop print number
and use them and they were often out for
several months on field assignments they
who are allowed an enormous amount of
latitude on these assignments to go off
the path to discover what there was to
photograph and then the images were
centrally developed and catalogued and
then they were sent out to all kinds of
venues all over the country once we
entered the war the Farm Security
Administration became the office of War
Information and became a outright war
homefront propaganda unit one of the
interesting things is how did all of
these sort of left-wing photographers
working in the depression for you know
federal intervention goes so seamlessly
into the office of War Information that
problem has interested me as a scholar
for years it has to do with an
understanding of what how they
understood anti-fascism but they did
this is an enormous government
propaganda outfit I and you know these
images what's less obvious but to New
Yorkers right now should be really
striking is that at this around the same
time there are other efforts that are
not
in the in the US government the one in
particular i'm talking about thinking
now about is the photo League which
there's an extraordinary exhibition at
the jewish museum of the photo league
right now it's up for a little while
longer and i urge you to go and see this
because that's really the photo League
origins can be traced back not to the
New Deal but to something called the
workers international relief project and
to the Communists association that was
based in Berlin and in the 1930s they
were giving they were giving cameras to
the workers and they were photographing
strikes something that in fact the FSA
when you when you go to the left of the
FSA you notice what the FSA was and
wasn't doing so there is an example of
the photo League some of the same
photographers the photo League register
is almost again all of the great
photographers of the 20th century Paul
strain for instances in both
organizations and um here are some names
from the photo League Sid Grossman Saul
leibson Walter rosenblum Arthur Eagle
loose Steinman and they actually also
had a lot of women unlike the FSA which
had some women but fewer women at the
end of the 1940s the the McCarthy
hearing the photo League was blacklisted
as a communist organization and they had
a large exhibition which was called here
is the photo League trying to say no
we're a multiplicity of voices the all
virtually all of the photographic
established you all all of the everybody
tried to support this but it went under
nonetheless and the people had careers
after that they were largely
first-generation American immigrants and
they are not supported by the government
I mean they're actually undermined by
the government and that
important to know as we study the FSA at
the same time also is the mass
observation project from 1937 to the
1950s in Britain again a social history
collection of documentary images in an
attempt to make England or make an image
of itself and this is a collection we
would call it crowd-sourced now where
they're asking people general citizens
to to hand in photographs diary accounts
there are people writing diaries of
every day in their life in the in the in
the 30s and um that's another really
fascinating mass based project so I
frame this for you so that you
understand sort of what the body of work
is that we're looking at and also
because I want to make a point about
digital humanities projects in general
I'm a historian of American photography
I'm thrilled to participate in this team
but I'm also as you can see older than
this team and I'm a historian I'm a
scholar one of the questions about all
of this fancy new incredible magical
technology we have is how to turn it
into meaning for scholarship not only
how to do it and how to see the
incredible new things you can find out
but how to attach these new things to
the stories the narratives that scholars
already have and I see that as my role
in this team so it's been fascinating to
me and the question is how does
scholarship how does somebody
representing this field of scholarship
take in and add to this new kind of
knowledge production so with that I
think we will we go to next the two of
ya so Taylor arnold n Lauren
well thank you all for having us and I'm
very excited to present about this
project and I'm really looking forward
to hearing what y'all had to say I were
going to switch over here to the area so
that pot was shaking a bit huh what's
cool um and as you see just from the
front slide here it takes a team and
many different areas to we think to make
a project like this this one happened
and thanks as well to the neh which is
funded this um bingo the first okay a
photo grammar I grew out of my
frustration with the FSA owi archive as
available online through the Library of
Congress here at your fingertips was one
of the nation's most prized photography
archives contain some of the nation's
most iconic images as you can see here
and yet the ability is searches
collection was really limited I was
trying to start him I was trying to do
research for a paper and the question
that was guiding me once I was really
interested in how the FSA Oh WIA
represented african-americans in the
south as the nation shifted to war and
you can tell prob I'm from the south so
this was a question I was curious of
that and the search functionality of the
website i found like really difficult to
start even trying to get at this kind of
question so as you can see here there's
a one search function that can present
the information for ways when one
searches a photographer the query
returns photographs at random there's no
advanced search by date photographer
graphic location or theme the next is a
gallery view and which removes much of
the information such as date type of
film and the photos record number next
is a grid that goes gone to further in
removing more information including the
captions and next is a slideshow tool
which i think is nice as a sort of a
trip down the next slide memory sort of
down memory lane here you kind of travel
through them and in sort of a not
necessarily clear way and this type of
search functionality
works well in many settings but for
researching within this expansive
archive the limits of a site also limits
the type of scholarship that can be
pursued pursued so adding to these
questions as I started doing this every
time I looked on the website and search
by a year or a state we started to see
the number of large number of photos
outside of the south or the Dust Bowl
which is sore the usual characterization
of this archive and as well as the
number of urban in us and photos comes a
US war machine and what's going on here
this is just doesn't add up to what
we've been told about what this archive
is so how could we get to get at these
questions and this sort of environment
so speaking with tayla Arnold who's
driving in the back right now and
statistics he suggested using
statistical methods which began to the
process of rien gauging how to think
through this and we're going to get to
where that let so the questions begin to
grow is there a different way we can
visualize a large collection of visual
material how does the way we organize
and visualize materials reshape how we
understand our object of study in this
case 170,000 photographs of the FSA and
is there a way we can reorganize
represent and augment this collection
that would make it easy directs excess
by the general public and for
researchers so with those sort of things
in mind the limitations of the current
archive infrastructure as well it's this
idea that could be even more expansive
public resource began the process of
putting together the team you see here
to rethink how we can reconstruct shua
lies this visual archive and so you see
the group here is professor Wexler and
Taylor and statistics can and our map as
I say our map ninja stacy aces and so as
a result we sort of joined together to
sort of to become a part of a longer
history of archivists and historians who
have been sort of responding to
limitations of the classification of
this archive so then we'll get back oh
it's a just a note we talked at the
Library of Congress and one of the
limits is the type of hardware and
software they can use they have to be
American with Disabilities Act compliant
which allows them not to be able to use
almost all of the tools we are using as
well as security concerns on their
servers and all these things and the
chief of Princeton photograph collection
Helena's increments income and Beverley
Brandan have done an amazing job to
optimize its archive within their
constraints and I just want to note that
they have done an incredible job and
they continue to do an incredible job
within their limitations and have been
really gracious to us to help work with
us took sort of we work and work with
this archive and I think it's really
important to know that they have been
amazing amazing collaborators with us so
i think is to go back a little bit to
the history of the FSA owi a bit from
nineteen thirty-five to forty three the
federal government under the Farm
Security Administration office of War
Information commissioned over 170,000
photographs under the direction of Roy
Stryker here he actually begin the first
filing system which classified the
photographs by state such as like
Illinois and then by headings which were
determined by assignment or subjects
such as farming photos were not placed
under not placed under a state were
filed under large subject category such
as business or food products and that
system has since is no longer in a great
antidote I think from documenting
America by Beverly Brandon and car wash
our at the library Congress they tell a
retelling store a telling story about
the struggle to get through this archive
Edwin Roskam who's next wrote in 1941
dear lord please put yourself in the
position of an unfortunate customer who
finds that drought exists in Oklahoma
New Mexico and among other things Texas
in each case he has given a heading he
has to hunt considerably under the
headings because there are always lots
of pictures in there besides and perhaps
he doesn't like the one he finds but
when he comes to Texas he goes through
13 drawers he even finds his heading so
can similar frustrations today but um
and so as a result in 1942 striker hired
paul vanderbilt to who began the
monumental task of reorganizing it
vanderbilt believe that the photograph
the way the photographs were filed
frame no type of knowledge one was going
to be able to gain from that archived
from the photographs the archival system
was a response to those types of
knowledge he organized 77,000 prints in
a new archival system organized by
region these are the end this with by
agricultural region such as north east
south east and then subject classes
which we are calling the filing cabinet
system for example if 112 find a picture
of manufacturing in the southwest one
they would go the filing cabinet the LOC
its and next slide and use a finding guy
to search for cabinet under southwest of
one bag southwestern US and then look
for the subject class numbers this is
like 53 365 titled work agriculture
commerce and manufacturing as well as
well he created another archival system
called lots each photo lot was a photo
assignment to just walk her head Evans
Hill County photographs and let us now
praise famous men are twenty two
thousand and twenty two thousand lots
were created including the 77,000
photographs printed by striker and the
11,000 prints collected from other
sources the Lots eighty percent were
microfilmed and the remainder were
placed in storage boxes where as
important is that of the 170,000
photographs only 77,000 were printed so
in the 1990s when the lse went and
digitized the entire collection just
from the negatives suddenly in 1990 we
had 170 thousand photographs now
depicting the the country at this time
and to give a sense of perspective in
order to look at every photograph for
three seconds which is billing of time
to read the captions it would take one
week of non-stop work or 190 hours so
this very issue of how to organize it
understand these photographs
particularly on this scale and forms a
photo grammar project and along along
with many more who have come to this um
so for example what was lost for many
scholars was the case of the
photographer many responded by releasing
works by Walker Evans of Dorothea Lange
and others um like Kara Finnegan have
looked at the circulations of the images
and print culture and historiography
just can't
used to grow but all are sort of in need
of better ways of accessing the material
so we believe that reimagining Andrey
visualizing this archive as well as
maintaining its historical archive
archival classifications so we don't
want to lose the history of archive as
we build this digital tool for it
because we think that that history was
incredibly important to it so so we
think that new questions would open up
and that this will be a resource for
scholars educators in the public at
large so with this goal in mind we turn
to other sciences including the social
sciences who frequently managed to make
qualitative and quantitative inferences
from datasets this sort of took it to
the next level merging my interest in
visual culture in particularly
photography with Taylor Elms interest in
for lack of a better term messy data
sets ah for him mrs. data suggested that
the incredibly rich but frustrating
ailing messy FSA could be it would be a
particularly good set of photographs on
which to try to apply new techniques of
statistical geospatial mapping as well
as to create a public online resource
and so this part of the photo camera
project began as a public humanities
project in Laura Wexler's Professor X
was wonderful class on in public
humanities which she's helped start that
program at Yale and it's been amazing
and and we began that here after we
scrape the image from the Library of
Congress website using our which is an
open-source programming language for
those more technical implementation of
the s programming language we began the
process of pleading the data for example
photographs from New Orleans may be
titled new olean's Orleans Parish
Louisiana we standardized this
information and Stacy can speak a little
bit more in depth about cleaning a
geospatial data and process for doing
that and then the information already
built into the marked records which you
see here which is the record system for
the Library of Congress includes
information that allows us to actually
reconstruct Vanderbilt's classification
system and lock system or the filing
caps are the file
cabinet system and malad system as well
as put together individual photographs
into strips which may be one of the
coolest things until it's going to talk
more about that and we think may be a
game changer and taylor and taylor will
speak to that i'm going to let him come
on up here and I'm gonna drive in the
back so as learn was saying if you go to
the website as it to the library of
congress website and you pull up a
photograph this is the record that
you'll see so you can see that we have
like the title well if it would stop
shaking we can see we can figure out the
title of this we can figure out who took
it we can figure out when it was taken I
think this one has where it was taken
and some subject headings and if we went
through other photographs some of them
would have this information and some
some would not but there are also a lot
of other pieces of information or I
think of them as data on this page that
are really really fascinating both both
to people like me and also to people
like Laura but because of because of
different for many different reasons and
one of them is that the library of
congress is limited to how they can
organize the data they can't do it
spatially they can't recreate these
strips like i'm going to show you in a
second so a lot of the information on
here which were very indebted that they
put up online is essentially useless to
most people who go to the website
because they don't know what it means so
i think if you go to the next slide so
so this is an image on that Vanderbilt
took in Chicago in 1941 it's you know
it's this man that he that he saw on the
street and so we were at the library of
congress two weeks ago and we actually
went and saw this this image on them so
you can see that there's a lot of
information about this about this
photograph and and I'm going to sort of
go through what that information is and
then how we can redisplay that in a way
that's useful to people rather than just
a number that doesn't mean anything so
you see this number here called so it
says other number F 323 does that mean
any want anything to anyone after three
to three now it's it's fairly useless um
because because you don't actually know
what that number means and the only way
to know what that means is to either go
to the live
Congress and I think if you go to the
next slide and that number tells me
where that where that print is in the
library of congress so i can go to the
drawer f and look at 323 and that stands
for individual men middle-aged in the
midwest and it's different than in group
men middle-aged or individual men old
age and I don't know where the cutoff is
I know some people would really like to
argue when you become older when you're
middle-aged but Vanderbilt when he made
this he made some distinction and this
guy is a strictly middle-aged and so
that number tells me not only where I
can find it but also what it was
categorized by the original system and
to a lot of scholars it's really
fascinating like why are their
individual men that are categorizes
differently as group men why are there
middle-aged young and old why are they
are why is there a break out for what's
a good example like railroad workers but
there's not a break out for grain
workers you know the the system is so
strange and arbitrary it's actually
really fascinating um but you don't get
that from the website i can now match it
up and show it to people and on the new
website you'll be able to actually look
at it that way but in the current
manifestation the data is there but it's
not presented in a form that most people
can use and so there's actually there's
more information on the there on the
number here there's this something
called lot 1 073 that probably doesn't
mean anything to anyone else but what it
means is that in that drawer do you have
a picture of the doors at the next no
okay um so we showed you that drawer
that had all of these little micro film
things and that actually tells me what
microfilm this lot what this photograph
is in so you can put the microfilm in
and go through and we unfortunately
chose an extremely long lot so we had to
sit there for 20 minutes looking for it
but it was in this lot of pictures from
chicago and again you know you wouldn't
really know what this number means or be
able to you can't search by lots on the
Library of Congress either but what this
lot is is it's all of the photographs
that VaShawn took in Chicago but
interestingly enough he went there twice
he went
the summer of forty-one in the summer of
40 well he may have done other times but
I know he went those two times and
they're all strung together just like at
random and so it's really fascinating to
me that Vanderbilt thought it was
interesting to put vashon Chicago photos
together but he didn't think of the
photographs as as a trip he didn't think
of it as maybe through the eyes of the
photographer they're not in any order
there are two pictures of the same guy
basically on the strain street corner
that are on totally different ends of
the lot so it's just really interesting
when you start to decode all of the
information that's on here and then be
able to redisplay it to someone
instantly on their computer so you don't
have to go in to the library of congress
and put in the microfilm and actually
figure out where this thing is so this
is the sort of information that we're
able to pull off of this thing here so
the other number the the catalog number
where the print is in the file the file
the file drawer classification system
and then the lot number and so those are
very interesting and then the the number
that is actually even more fascinating
the one that ken was alluding to that he
thinks is very cool is this you can see
there's a library of congress number so
i don't know if i can read it it's to
have it here well it's a long string of
numbers that tells that is how the lover
of congress um de marks there there's
their negatives so it's 0 1 6 165
something like that and then there's a
dash m4 and so I thought that was just a
useless number again my whole talk is
about use those numbers that aren't
useless and so m4 is really interesting
because what that's what that means is
that somewhere in the back where they
have the actual so almost a lot of the
film was done on 35 millimeter rolls of
film and then cut up into five or six
frames and put in the back and I guess
that was the easiest way to sort of
develop them is on these strips of five
or six film I don't know anything about
film so so I've just been told this um
yes um um so anyway so but what the m4
means is that actually it tells me that
it's the fourth frame on one of these
strips of film and if I look at a holdup
and if I look at the the same number
dash and 3 i'll get the one that was
taken right before that and so it's very
interesting that i can put back these
photos back together in and the the data
is all there it's just not in any in any
way that anyone going to the website
would know to do this and so here we
actually have each row is something i
was able to put back together using
these m numbers so it's m 1 m 2 and 3 m
1 m 2 and 3 and 4 and so those are the
strips that I know we're taken in this
order and then you can actually see that
we put them in we've been able to once
they're in a strip I can actually see if
it will stop moving that all three of
the ones at the top I know that they're
in Wisconsin in Kenosha Wisconsin and
they were taken by that Sean in the same
month and so we were able to put them
back together almost in the way that
they would be on a roll which is very
cool because we can start to actually
construct his whole trip again instead
of these random photos that that aren't
near anything and well and the other
thing is that some of these photos I
don't remember exactly which ones but
for instance the middle row you can see
there's a cheese market all the way on
the left and there's no information if
you go to the website the Library of
Congress there's no information about
this photograph it just says it's part
of the FSA owi don't know who took it
don't know when don't aware but the the
rest of the roll it's a or some of the
other ones on the roll it says it's
vashon in 41 in Kenosha and so unless
you know you know Miriam post Wolcott
stole that Sean's camera and you know
used his film this is probably vashon
right before they're in it's a cheese
shop so I'm actually pretty certain of
this and so we can begin to fill in a
lot of the data that's missing on that's
really fascinating and and on the fourth
the fourth row here what's even more
interesting is that you can see that we
we have these cheese shops so this is
him still in Wisconsin but then at the
end of the row the there's a guy sitting
on the street
one of them is has no information but
the other one it says it's Beth Shawn in
Chicago at 41 and so it's really
fascinating is that we know that this is
the first thing he took a photo of when
he was in Chicago because this was the
role that was left over on his way in
from Wisconsin and so before you had a
lot and you had 100 photos he took him
out no idea when he took them was this
the last thing he saw was as the first
thing and now we actually know like this
guy on the side of the street is the
very first thing he saw when he got
there and so another historian but I've
been told that this is interesting so so
yeah so so that's pretty cool and then
we started to put these back together
and then and then when we can put the
put the actual strips back together so
we can go to the next slide so so so
sort of zooming out from one photo two
strips two rolls another thing that we
can do is once I have all of the data I
can i can map it and try to figure out
visually and spatially over time where
all of these photographers work because
i think is Lauren was alluding to a lot
of people think of this is a archive of
the rural South and there are a lot of
rural southern photos but they're
actually photos all over the country and
you know in cities in Chicago and in
Maine in in the West and so I was able
to actually sort of highlight as the
years go by how the density of
photographs so you can see County sort
of light up as Lauren goes through here
so you can just go to through 245 and so
you can start to see see you can see
that as we move into the war years they
that the archive becomes even less
southern and less rural and more about
the industrial north and the West and
see my state of Maine lights out that's
kind of cool and you can see so this
maps very neat because you can actually
see I think we decided with Rothstein
right you can actually see I don't know
if you can see this resolutions are well
but there's a streak of counties that go
across yeah exactly and those are
actually all of him taking this trip
across the west
and so we've been working with best Sean
but hopefully we can dig into that
archive to and put those strips back
together and actually get his whole trip
and see like well what did you see at
the beginning what you see in the middle
would you see in the end and actually
gives some temporal peace to these
photographs that are always looked at
sort of in all these different ways but
haven't been able to be looked at
spatially and buy time so if you can go
to the next one so well yeah so I'll
show this first and then i'll show you
sort of a prototype of the website
that's going to let you actually do all
of this stuff that i can do locally on
my computer you know at your own desks
or direct students to or classrooms to
so they can play around with the photos
and figure out you know just give me a
density map of where where Mary and post
wawa was in July of 43 and you can light
up those counties and click on the
counties and see where she was so the
last thing is we're trying to like dive
in and get as much information out of
this as we can so this is that Sean and
41 so I don't have the exact days but
it's a summer of forty-one and so
there's a dot on the map of everywhere
that we know he was because as I said he
labeled some photographs where he was
but not very not very consistently and
and the dates are sort of well it's a
month in a year and it's not like I was
here on at tea-time on the 14th so you
don't know exactly when he was somewhere
but this these are all of the places you
was on that summer he started in DC and
then ended up back in TC and so we
started going into this set of images
and tried to try to reconstruct it when
we'd eventually like to do this with all
of them but this is sort of our side
project at the moment so if you click to
the next slide so the first thing is I
really just needed a baseline to figure
out exactly we're a baseline to say well
let's just give it some ordering and
then I can tweak it and so there's this
problem in computer science called the
Traveling Salesman problem so it's you
have a bunch of cities and you need to
visit them all and what's the shortest
distance on that you can do that in
because given new information I'm just
going to assume that he went to the
cities in the best order possible and if
you think
roston going across the country he
probably didn't like jump back and forth
you probably took a smooth path across
the country and so this is actually sort
of a really interesting computational
problem because there are more paths
between these 20 cities then there are
second since the Big Bang so it's just
huge it's like a hundred million
trillion has and so there's some real
computational work that needs to be done
to calculate this so our problem is is a
little different it's just that we know
a starting point in an ending point and
I need to figure out how to go in
between them so I had to I had to do
some computational stuff under the hood
to get this variant of the problem so if
you go to the next slide but then as
you're all sort of thinking or
whispering well that's not going to be
exactly how people travel they sort of
there they're going and we were reading
bastions letters and he laments to his
wife my god I can't find any cows you
know they want me to take pictures of
cows and I can't find any cows and so he
probably wasn't taking the most direct
route to find these cows he's probably
driving around in circles and so we we
tried to the best of our ability to fill
in the blanks when we could and so here
you have the very beginning of his trip
and I know that these were all all at
the beginning because they were all in
June or what I knew that they were all
in the same month so he's in like Erie
Pennsylvania and then Pittsburgh and
then Columbus and then somewhere else in
Ohio but then once we started looking at
his letters so if you go to the next
slide I actually know because I we have
the postmark date of his letters so we
just couldn't that say that he was in
Pittsburgh in on jun 13 and then here on
the next slide so these are his
transcripts of his letters that on june
seventeenth he was in erie pennsylvania
so he didn't actually take this shortest
route he went from pittsburgh up to erie
and then over to ohio and so we start
editing our map a little bit and we can
keep doing this um so as I said we can
also use where these frames fit together
so the shortest path would be to first
go to Chicago and then up to Wisconsin
but so go to the next slide but we know
that that's not the case because
remember I
saw him go from Wisconsin to Chicago so
we can edit the map a little bit more
and he went up to Madison and took route
41 down into chicago and then we started
doing this with all of the letters and
so this is sort of the resulting path
that we have this seems the most likely
using the letters and then when we don't
know the letters just saying well you
probably took the shortest path and then
you can click through and so we just
have the rest of his summer through and
then so then we have his whole path and
then we can start to put the photographs
back into order and then where we can
put them into strips and strips into
rolls and rolls into trips and so while
it's not going to be a hundred percent
accurate it's going to be ninety-five
percent accurate and we can start to see
the photographs through the eyes of the
photographer which is not the way the
archive is set up now it's sort of set
up in this thematic way or this you know
I want all of the Chicago photos but the
Chicago photos were taken the same
afternoon as Kenosha Wisconsin and so
it's just a different way to think about
these photographs and really lends
itself to some new forms of scholarship
so if you want to go to yeah so this is
that slide I was showing you before so
and then this is this is him actually in
chicago so just more examples of it so
you can see him growing on the l system
and him going around the fountains and
when we were in chicago we actually sort
of walked around and figured out where
exactly he was going and so just getting
more and more detail as we go through
this collection so do you go to the
website um so the website sort of in
development that's what's that's what
sort of the whole team is working on can
in the eye to your gaze of this project
we just got started yeah so on and if
you go to localhost no that won't work
see localhost and then get rid of get
rid of test yeah just go there thanks so
this is sort of this is if you go to
photo grammar org you'll see this and
you'll get very excited and nothing will
work so don't get too excited or even go
right now but probably will change the
message will change in the next few
months and i'm going to make everybody
go but so this is our temporary this is
our testing website and so if you click
on interactive maps
you can see this is a the map is sort of
shaded based upon how many photographs
were taken in that state and then if you
can can you click on County so you can
go to the county level which is a little
more interesting and it takes a second
to load and so will actually see that
map that I showed you before over the
whole span of the FSA shaded and so if
you go where you can click on something
in Louisiana to make you happy but if
you click on Plaquemines Parish now yes
so now we get a whole grid of all of the
photographs from that area and so this
is sort of this is how we're starting to
think of the archive but at least now we
have sort of a spatial way of thinking
about this thing entering the archive in
a way that you didn't used to and what
we think about this as some sort of a
public humanities perspective it's very
cool is that when you interact with
people you interact with them locally
and in communities and people think
about people are interested in seeing
photographs from where they live and
every time I showed this to someone they
say oh can you find my county like can I
click on my county and so what we think
is really cool about this is you know if
I go back to like my home town in Maine
or Lauren takes us to like New Orleans
are you can you can instantly see all of
the photographs from your street your
neighborhood what was going on in your
area in the 30s and well you can sort of
search and do this in a way on the
current website is not sort of like in
your face the way that it is now on our
website so that's sort of where we're
going and so you can just go back oh and
then I'm the lot number this is the
other thing is that weren't actually
sort of building in naturally all of
these organizational systems like the
lot numbers and the catalog number so i
think lauren just or she just pulled up
that lot that i was telling you about
the one where we found this guy in
Chicago so if he's in here somewhere so
picture picture doing this on a tiny
little micro film film thing that
jiggles and makes noise and now you can
just look at it all on the computer
quickly and so that's um that's him
right there and so while we're still
building this out as I said right now it
just links back to the library of
congress but it's letting you see all of
these different organizations as well as
new ones of the photo
graphic collection in a way that you
can't interact with it on the LSC
website so just going back to the slide
show briefly and so some other things
because on a statistician and I like fun
fun graphics can I think if you do a
view and then do slideshow it'll get
bigger exactly there you go um so some
visualizations we can do with this so to
what I've been describing now is taking
the collection and reorganizing its data
but other things we can do is we can
actually pair it with other did it's not
even in this collection so one thing is
here I can take all of the photographs
where people took all of the locations
where people took photographs and pair
it with historical census data and so
here I have all of the photograph that
photographers sort of laid out with
Walker Evans not surprisingly all the
way at the left as the one who had the
least urban photographs if he was always
in these like desolate das police
southern places and then on the other
side side i have like Arthur Siegel and
I can't read them Stacy who else is on
there Siegel Lieberman okay right so so
we can start to sort of play around and
a lot of this is just fun for right now
but but we do think that once people can
interact with these sorts of graphics
dynamically that they'll at least at
least two people who aren't even
familiar with this collection can
instantly think of Oh what do what do I
think of the sort of counties or the
sort of photos that Walker Evans takes
as opposed to you know Marion post
Wolcott so and then the other thing that
we read about about sean is that he
really likes to go from he likes to look
for cows and he likes to be right
downtown cities and so we thought I'd be
cool since we had already charted his
his journey to take all of the the
county this is from the 1930s census the
density of the counties and so you can
see that light lighter is sort of urban
counties and then darker is a darker is
more urban and then the lighter is more
rule it is and so you can see he's going
from like Chicago now
Detroit and then he's going into the
middle of nowhere you know looking for
cows and things and so that's sort of an
interesting way of seeing his journey
that you wouldn't you wouldn't see just
looking at sort of all the photographs
at once and then you click on through we
also took so the captions that they
wrote they always wrote like a little
caption about some of their photographs
like this is a picture of a farmer on
his horse or something and so I took all
of them and built these little word
clouds and so the bigger words were used
more and then they're smaller and
smaller as as the words weren't used and
so like farm for instance is there
because he wrote Farm Security
Administration a lot but it's bigger
than administration insecurity because
he also talked about farms and so if you
go to the one that I thought was pretty
interesting is Miriam post Wolcott and I
don't think I think I could have read I
think he could have studied her for two
decades and never known this is that she
always likes to describe things as being
near to other things near is huge and if
you look at her captions it's like
two-thirds of them or a half of them
have near it's always I took this
picture near the local pup or something
you know I took this near a cornfield
and so there's no there was really
interesting and I would never really
figure that out having Reddell reading
all the captions one by one but on this
it was just like in your faith near
that's how she describes everything and
when and then once I went back through
it was really apparent and then this is
walker evans and obviously you get like
kale county and street floods and brews
and sort of things you would expect to
get so so this is just sort of half
having fun but it's also you know what
we can start doing with this when we
think of it as data and then taking the
data back out and doing a close reading
of things once you actually look at the
data so for instance the near thing is
kind of cool I don't really know what
that means but if Laura then goes back
and studies her and this is something
she can know in the back of her head and
maybe there's something really
interesting about that so that's just
that's sort of our workflow so with that
I'll just hand it back to Lauren so I
just to pull a few pieces together here
um photo grammar we conceive of it as a
digital humanities and a public
humanities project and it's great being
cleaning geo-locating sort of core
aspect to the former and then the
ability to create strips we construct
information about the photographs
including
photographer date location and use
metadata or Foreman out in a forms of
analysis or made possible by digital
humanities techniques including
statistical methods which opened up
methods such as mapping and statistics
data visualization to make new forms of
analysis possible the public humanities
aspect this project will be a Fiat
freely available at photo grammar or
sort of the guiding question here is how
can such a large collection be made
available and accessible to the public
part of the foam photo grammar project
will include be able to create
interactive database the FSA RW
photographs based on all this is open
source database standards and so you'll
be able to pull the data out in plain
text CSVs that can be read into other
languages if you'd like to use it in
that way this will allow images to be
viewed downloaded organized and it saves
electronically by searching in several
combinations of data characteristics
youjizz will be able to individually
search the database through the
interactive map that plots these
photographs and this will also be
plotted over census data as well and one
piece we're also looking into it's
actually trying to get also some
historical information to plot over as
well historical event particular
interest in the new wing and maybe
timelines about when New Deal policies
went into quite so you can contextualize
this archive within its framework of a
government program which is something
law has really been great in helping us
think through even even more critically
and as well users will be able to track
individual photographer so you'll be
able to watch like Marion post cops
County's light up as she travels over
time these will be timelines that you
can follow photographers as well yes
your track the photographer's at a later
stage we're hoping if there's more
funding comes along will be maybe a
large crowd sourcing tagging project
that we think would really be amazing
imagining what the Library of Congress
has done a very very small piece of and
I'll Flickr and has gotten amazing
results they've said that almost every
night similar ninety percent of the
information they're getting from users
is accurate and good
information there have incredible
success crowdsourcing we've asked this
of several groups I knew that that's one
of the questions I get asked a lot about
crowdsourcing how good is your data how
is that information they've had
wonderful success with it so we'd like
to build off that as well and so this
would also allow you to do is hopefully
people tag things like military images
could you get a percentage of
military-to-military images collected by
month and location or maybe see a
gallery sharecropping that we really
start to really rethink how you organize
as you see the map is sort of the
organizational mechanism for the data
and and we're looking at also on this is
right now historic County you are
looking at historic County information
but some tiles that you're seeing as
well as looking as copyright & fair use
rules are changing as we speak about the
best way to use on historical maps and
what maps we actually can overlay on
this that's sort of an open question
because we are working in a period of
snow copyright issues a fair use but
sort of open yeah so those are things
are changing quickly which is always
great and maybe states can speak a
little bit to that um we also think that
mapping it may be over contemporary
spaces will allow for public projects
thinking of rifa tog raphy projects
sending your students out the city to go
find these images mapping them doing fun
pedagogical ways of mechanisms another
way so yeah so the map um and we think
that by seeing the points on an
interactive geospatial maps you can
transform your current paradigms of the
collection sort of a simple and static
archive of images that you can actually
follow people it becomes a dynamic tool
viewable an array of spatial temporal
and topical dimensions and that will be
a think tools that we can keep growing
on the one thing another pedagogical
tool as well as um putting some lesson
plans tile things on it so that for
example um
what do you see then what do you what do
you see this we enjoy themselves if you
hadn't given caption what would your
caption d they always close the box
anyway yeah well you can do this in
classrooms in many fun environments if
you hit the next slide what is it what
does it change when you see the caption
how does it change what you think you're
seeing where do you think you are these
sort of things that we think will make
it a tool that can be usable along sort
of a ray of educational environments so
I think I'm in some I think they're at
the core of photo grammar as a effort to
show how to offer an extensive
photography archive as a searchable
visual and participatory online tool
that can inform and shape scholarship
and public engagement and I think at
this point let maybe Stacy and can talk
about ok so I'm a bad guy and so I've
been thinking about three things so I've
been thinking about geocoding and right
now I've been thinking about three
things geocoding the collection itself
so taking the information about where
each of the photos was taken and turning
that basically into just a lap long
Taylor condemned report with and using
the ways that he wants to to use it the
other two things I'm thinking about is
the demographic data how do we get
demographic data from 1930 1940 put it
into a format that you can look at sort
of the way I think of it is looking at
the demography of the collection against
the demography of the actual human
population of being photographed and so
we've been pulling down data the data
that Taylor is using I think is from the
national historic GIS project which is a
project that has digitally mapped in in
a GIS friendly way all of the census
data at the county level back to 1790 so
we're using that as as demographic data
and then I've also been thinking about
base map data we can throw it on top of
Google Maps and Google Maps or an
open-source version of Google Maps like
Open Street Map will probably be one of
the available base maps but we also want
to put it in too it's only temporal
context and so I was really excited
yesterday to go to a meeting about fair
use that was presented by the ARL
association of research librarians sort
of an overview of their new best
practices on fair use which if you
haven't seen it please go get it now how
many librarians go get it and read it
cover to cover and go listen to Brandon
I can't remember his last name talk
about this when he comes and did you say
in two weeks on Tuesday go listen to
this talk it is critical for you it's a
paradigm shift so now we have not been
able to scan and use materials based on
our fear of
whether or not it falls within fair use
or not post 1923 and that's kind of
important for this project and and so
now I find that because our use is
transformational it falls under fair use
I can take our collection of several
thousand roadmaps in the United States
and I can scan them and I can build a
base map like google but google maps for
1930 and 1940 and that is what will
probably end up using for for the main
base map for this application and it all
be covered under fair use because those
maps were originally used to well they
were originally created probably more
for advertising than anything of the old
gas station maps but they were intended
to be used to travel across the road
system that has been changed so
completely that they're useless for
their original intent so but mainly what
I've been thinking about up to this
point is geo coding and and here's my
problem we've got a hundred and seventy
thousand images we've got 107 of the miz
records because they're the records in a
database Taylor and I are on the same
page here so we've got 170 thousand
records of those hundred and seventy
thousand records 90,000 have a location
associated with them and then of those
locations that are associated with those
ninety thousand records that have
location there are four thousand unique
locations and so that's one way you know
you can bring it down and make it more
manageable and so I had to find a way
that fit within the parameters of what
we wanted to do with the project open
the source using using things that are
covered under Creative Commons licensing
to lice to geocode this and 4000
locations is still a significant problem
unless you want to pay a lot of money to
to geocode those addresses and those
locations the other problem is that some
of those locations don't well they exist
but they have different names now and so
how do you geocode locations that have
different names how do you go back in
time and find these these counties or
these populated places and place names
that no are no longer named what they
were in the past and so the answer for
us for me was geonames organ and this is
an open source public facing geocoding
engine you can go to geonames org and
type in a location and then just get
geospatial information about that single
location but you can also do it
programmatically they have eight million
place names and this is a global data
set they have eight million place names
all over the world and those place names
include data from the national
geospatial-intelligence agency the
Geographic Names information system the
from the board on Geographic Names USGS
place names the the Arctic place names
project and also some historic place
name project so Harvard is beginning to
experiment with putting their China
historical data database into this
interface and also the counties from the
national historic GIS are in this
database as well so it was a perfect
answer the other thing that was great
about it was there's essentially no
limits how much geocoding so one of the
big problems when I was looking
engines was how many geocodes could we
do in an hour and a day and so on
because experimenting and geocoding is
iterative so this was great you can do
2,000 an hour and thirty thousand a day
no problem week we can live with that
and it's covered under the creative
commons attribution license as long as
you give them credit for the geocoding
you do whatever you want so this is
apologize that this looks very technical
but this is how you get a geocode out of
a place name in in geonames org and it's
just a URL it's what you what you would
see if you if you enter a place name
into the application into the search box
and then got a return what you would see
at the top and your address bar is this
you know you're not interested in this
you're interested in information about
the place but because it's a URL and
it's structured like this so you see the
HTTP up at the top everybody know what
knows what that is that's where the
server lives and then we tell it that we
want to do a search and here is our
query and I want to limit to a
particular country I want to limit it to
a particular feature class in this case
and I want to limit it to a particular
continent because the u.s. is expensive
and we have interests and place names
listed under US and other countries so I
just wanted to limit it to North America
here even though there are quite a few
images in this database that are outside
north america and then i had to put my
username in there so they could count my
quota and tell it how I wanted the date
of that pretty simple but I had to do
this four thousand times so I didn't
want to sit there and of course type in
the four thousand records I still have
four thousand record problem so what I
stumbled upon hockley and I
use this all the time if you work with
data at all especially dirty data and
these are mark records and I apologize
to all of you who are librarians but for
those of us in working with data Marc
records are really problematic because
they are it's a strange database format
and so Google refine it's actually right
now an open source project and you can
download this engine that works in your
browser but it works locally on your own
machine that helps you clean up data it
does so in intuitive ways by fastening
you know searches on particular fields
and so on and one so one of the things I
did was using Google refine as I
standardized names that were similar it
does clustering so if you have
Washington DC and DC washington and run
or run a cluster analysis you can you
can change those you can make them all
Washington DC if you have little rock
arkansas and Little Rock comma Arkansas
you can you can standardize that as well
and get your number of hits down next
and then finally what I did was I ran a
frequency analysis on the on the
geographic component of the of the
project so that I just had the place
names once i had standardized them all
in the large database and that's what I
geocoded so I had you know I'm only
showing 10 records here because it's
easier to do that in terms of memory
space but you can see the number of
records associated with each of the
places here that I created and so what I
did was I took that remember that URL
that big ugly thing that's kind of scary
looking I took it in there and I added
just one little piece if I can get back
here one little piece of code that told
the the URL that what I want to use for
the place name is the value of this
field right here and that returned for
me a piece of
called JSON this is this is the yellow
part is the part I put in there that
returns something called JSON which
looks even worse but it's got these two
really fantastically important things in
it it's got the longitude and the
latitude of that place name and that's
what I was after it just a little bit
i'm not a code monkey so this is really
actually quite simple to put together
for somebody who just knows a little bit
about how urls work and things like that
so a little bit of a code would parse
through that big terrible string and
pull out the longitude and the latitude
for me and allow me to give those
longitudes and latitudes to all the
place names and then what I could do
since I standardize all my place names i
just join that back to the main database
and it joins however many times it needs
to took the main database and what that
then allows us to do is take a photo
like this in abbeville louisiana did
that dan thinks of this guy fixing his
bike and place it in its geographic
context put a mark on the map where that
photo is aggregate the number of photos
per county and things of that sort so
very briefly the next step is to go to
the National Historic GIS and figure out
how to take this base data the census
data and put it in to a visual format
that is intuitive for people who want to
browse the photography and also look at
demography of the photographic
collection and then finally scanning the
road maps and all
a lots of fun too i Lester that's it
yeah so a little bit technical but if
your geocoding collections it's really
not that difficult if you have
geographic information and lots of the
collections have G information of that
event subject headings if I could
encourage all librarians to use the oh
34 field from now on for everything that
would be so wonderful bounty coordinates
and and point coordinates are fantastic
so that's odd that's it create and I'll
just add a couple of brief thoughts
because we've been here while you've
heard a lot already so again I'm manager
of digital humanities and the thing that
I just wanted to talk to you about was
I've been doing a lot of reflecting as
this project is now kind of up on its
feet and they're working through it
about those of us who work in and with
libraries if we want to do this kind of
work if this is the kind of research
that we want to enable on our campuses
what do we need to do what kind of skill
sets do we need in our libraries and in
our technology organizations and how do
we go about doing this work to actually
make it happen and one of the things
that I found interesting in just
thinking about this talk today was that
the genesis of this project was in
barber invited us here today but was in
something that Barbara and I worked on
together and professor Wexler was very
kind in inviting us to come to her
public humanities class in which Lauren
was a student to talk a little bit about
digital humanities and I think that was
one of the seeds of this project as
Lauren says hey there's people here who
will actually help me with answer these
questions that I have and likewise we
co-founded something called the digital
humanities working group of the Whitney
humanity Center on our campus which was
a form we run up like a seminar of it
gave people who were interested in these
things a place to come together and just
meet each other if nothing else when we
read
some literature in the field of digital
humanities but the most important thing
was when we just sat down and talked to
each other when we were done having our
coffee and cookies and things like that
it but I think that's hugely important
that we've got to get out of the library
sometimes we have to do things that
would enable a professor to see us as a
teammate as professor Wexler does thank
you very much for that too but you know
we know that that's a challenge because
many scholars in the humanities many
professors in the humanities still have
this concept of the lone scholar that's
really so but the more that we can show
examples of the potential of these sorts
of things I think the more they'll
invite us into their classes into
meetings and things like that and one of
the ways to do that is to sell this not
on that's why we talk about this word
digital as part of digital cammies being
kind of contentious right that a lot of
people have this sort of reflex reaction
against that of oh well I'm humanists
I'm not digital humans that's not what I
do that what you saw today sure we
couldn't have done these things without
technology but what was that the core of
it was discovered that that's what we
were enabling here wasn't too you know
enabling the code that the Taylor wrote
or the geocoding that you did or the
scholarship you it was what was most
important to discovery and I think
that's the message we have to sell as we
want to try to promote this kind of work
and then the one other thing was it's
been interesting cuz I don't think we're
at Yale at a very different point than
you guys are at Columbia in terms of
where we are providing staff and
resources to do this kind of work I
think we're both you know we there have
been some some work done in this but
we're now we're thing about how we can
formalize it and go forward with it and
so we're asking ourselves the same
questions if we're going to have a
center in the library that is going to
enable this kind of work what kind of
skill sets do we need represent it there
and I've always assumed that yet we need
text encoding because I was sort of one
of the first big splashes in in the
humanities and that you know we know
we're going to need some programmers
because they're the ones who have to do
this but I think there's almost every
digital humanities project that's been
proposed to us so far has a geographic
component to it you know Stace and i
have sat down in coffee shops with
countless professors
everything is somewhere yeah remember
and that matters and you've got to have
that I mean most libraries probably have
a GIS specialist but its key and the
other thing though is most libraries
also have data specialists but Taylor
skill set is also one that can really
thought necessarily about being
absolutely necessary but I think it is
absolutely necessary and that's somebody
who has just a very strong data and
stats background because none of this
could have been made possible without
that expertise either and that's another
area that I think is interesting that
those of you who work in humanities
libraries reach out to your
statisticians as well because we sort of
think of statisticians as social
scientists and that sort of thing and I
don't know that's necessarily the case
the social sciences have just been the
ones that have given statisticians these
cool messy data sets that they like to
work with in really interesting problems
to solve and I think we can do the same
thing in the humanities as well so I
think that's alright most about
perspective so we have a little time to
share with you comments reactions
this is really fabulous I actually met
with a student yesterday for a
consultation who was looking for images
that exactly from this data set and and
thinking about his questions coming to
this what did the people wear what would
they look like sitting on porches what
songs did they sing so my question to
you is you touched on a little bit when
you're talking about VaShawn about
looking at his letters and I wonder are
you imagining a textural component to
this of really mining text of that you
have so much keyword and metadata
attached to these images of that the
photographer's used to describe and from
Library of Congress subject
classification and so on it are there
words that you are you thinking about
tying and somehow mapping to the
personal reflections of the
photographers themselves short answer
yes whether or not we would be doing you
know keywords those word clouds I don't
know but absolutely pudding making
linking to or putting all the relevant
scholarship Roy strikers papers for
instance the there's a legend that there
are a lot of shooting scripts I always
thought there were these shooting
scripts it turns out when we went down
to the library of congress and Beverly
and Helen to know this there are very
few shooting scripts there were dinners
at Strykers house and there were
conversations but there are very few
students who so we should get the
shooting scripts and they should be up
there and we can see that there are a
few shooting script so yes there's all
this ancillary information then there's
as Lauren said there's just a huge
amount growing continually of
scholarship and that should be linked as
well we're thinking of a publication
we're just at the beginning yes yes yes
this is all very interesting the
impression I get is that you're
organizing and documenting this visual
archive 30s and 40s and I would like to
suggest that once you've made enough
headway you ought to think of expanding
your project to include the rest of the
visual culture from those two decades
paintings films and correlate the images
well it's a wonderful idea I mean the
music for instance where there's
brilliant folk yeah that all of that
could be connected the film archives
which are also at the library of
congress could be can I you know I agree
with you it would be fabulous so the way
I expressed that is that we need to have
the historical timelines historical
events but they would it for me include
production of cultural production as
well and what are thousands rifles yeah
but we also have other things to do I
think it's worth noting that when we
were at the grant we intentionally made
everything open source with the idea
that someone could come along with a
different set of information WPA any
slew of these items and could take any
of our code any of it and you can pull
it off and do whatever you want with it
I think that's important
so yeah I think what's really nice about
it Toni doing so there are all the
things words and so like like Laura was
mentioning these other photo archives I
would love but they're never sort of
privately owned and privately collected
and so they're not in the public domain
and so we can't really do the same thing
unfortunately with it and you'd have to
go you have to go back into the 1910s or
something because you just run into
copyright issues and we tried to think
of this not only as a project but as a
platform so we're working on a project
but what will come out of it is a
platform that other people can take and
do whatever they want with um yeah I
just wanted to sort of follow up about
the mapping sure I mean that was
fascinating were working on a project of
Brooklyn photographs of Brooklyn and
when we talk about like the mapping and
the geo-locating it always sound like
like this enormous project that would be
something separate that we couldn't
possibly undertake and you made it look
very simple was it is it actually that
simple it's simple except that you run
into you know there's little gotchas
along the way that you have two things
that you clean up it's simple but it
takes a while because you do have to
clean up the data and things like that
but but Google refine is very intuitive
it feels easy to use and if you're used
to using Voyager or inputting data and
or you know Marc records and things like
that then you're familiar with that sort
of data environment it really does
become quite easy if you have Geographic
data it is not a monumental task to turn
it into you know if you have implicit
geographic data place names it is not a
monumental task to turn it into explicit
Geographic data which is flat long is
that that's that's great the way making
sound cuz you know I mean the whole
thing with Brooklyn photographs is
that's really what people want is to
find you know their street or you know
you know their neighborhood yeah we'd
love to talk to you later if there's
some time when you could come and work
with us and how thank you thank you four
ever two points of information and quest
tied to this gentleman's you mentioned
where did he go you working on perhaps
Arthur Rothstein as another person and I
just wanted you to be aware that we
recently acquired from the family his
papers which include his day by day
diaries of his shoots he's got this book
yeah it's in addition to a full set of
his images which is a magnificent
collection we'd be delighted to work
with you on the Rothstein it has not yet
been processed so there's plenty of work
for all of us I to do that that's in the
Avery architectural and fine arts
library which is part of columbia
university libraries and i guess that
what that says to me is while this
gentleman was asking for breath
extending into other visual media or
other types yeah other other well
cultural whether it's visual or other
areas of culture output but the idea of
death and how will do you envision
scholars or archivists or other people
who contribute to the body of work
contributing to the projects such as the
arthur osteen archives are very rich in
deep and would be great to be able to
add those i'm sure that your grant sighs
do this do this and you're thinking in
platform terms what are the discursive
spaces you're imagining for the platform
or what are ways that additional data
could add to start-up grant this is then
we're six months into this so you can
see actually that in all in just six
months all of this has been done but we
don't this is this is just an original
swipe at this rate really so so yes we
are i am actually continually trying to
think about what are the discursive
spaces for this where should they be
should we be going around the country
and doing presentations literally in
town halls and churches and should we be
which other archival partners should we
be linking with and we're beginning to
look
that about partnerships the idea that
you're excited about it and think that
other visual material could come into
this is very gratifying because we're
trying to create a structure that would
be enticing and seemed capacious for
other people's scholarship other other
other things as well so we're just
beginning to understand what that is
crowdsourcing actual print publications
talking we've been going around talking
about it and the invitation other people
to say hey we could use that too or we
have this archive we're concerned with
that all yeah what yes we have been
trying to make a foundation that what
other people would think oh if I put
this material on that it would get
deeper and wider and we could see things
about the culture that we couldn't see
in any other way that's what I think
we're trying to do have you had any
feedback from the Library of Congress
and would they be interested in applying
your search capabilities for instance to
their website there during their spring
break we've been there several times
yeah essentially the impression that
we've gotten from them largely morin can
correct me if this is wrong is that they
were very excited about what we're doing
they're always happy to have us come and
visit and talk to us and tell us more
about the archive and have us run around
and do whatever we want and they're very
supportive of our project but they're
very hesitant to sort of formally
partner with us because that means a lot
of things politically and like
financially for them and it would mean a
lot more things we would have to do like
88 compliance we'd have to have new
security measures and all that sort of
thing and so I think where we are right
now is sort of this friendly
communication with them where
hurley knows us and you know all the
curators there are no us and so always
in communication with them but not
really a formal partnership just because
it's so it's so politically charged to
do anything like that with the Elysee
that would that would have to be way
down the line yeah yeah yeah I think
that's absolutely right yeah no I think
we have time for just one more question
sir no okay well thank you this was
fabulous it's amazing